[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's thursday you tapped into the group
chat live on the bluetooth
uh sponsored by fanduel uh you're proof
listen if you missed out on
the most recent sneakers drop or if you
missed out on the latest nba top shop
drop
we're glad you're with us because you
won't miss out on these special draw
special props that we're about to drop
my name is gabby richards our betting
expert is in the middle
that is kelly stewart and we're always
rolling with the talented mr ivory
speaking of talent every week we go
head-to-head with the great charles
barkley
in our chuck versus america segment and
you guys pick the prophets we generally
rock with you america
and chuck takes it out last week we
decided to ride together in the three by
two
in the brooklyn versus la game the three
by two is simply
whether it be two three-pointers made in
the first three minutes of the game
let's take a look at nets versus lakers
40 three-point attempts and the nets hit
20 of them
that's a three from outside and deandre
jordan coming off the bench
kai reed the only starter on the floor
and luaboo cabaret knocks in that shot
from outside
we can assure you that the three by two
hit we just have to show you a little
love
show some love to tyler johnson and to
tlc but
we assure you the three by two hit in
the brooklyn and la game so let's just
take a look at the standing shall we
in chuck versus america chuck decided to
fade us he went with the no
but look at the standings he drops to
five and five in america there we are
shining at nine and one
so greg you know every time that we're
in the lead feel free to hand out some
hoodies my g
cabbie is it time it's time well first
off this is the last
thursday of black history so i have to
show my show my
show my shirt black history is golden
but uh
this is the handy dandy ipad right here
and uh we're gonna get right into it if
you guys don't know what this
is i'm gonna introduce it to you right
now the handy dandy ipad and this is how
you win the hoodie so i'ma dive in
let's go cabbie uh jamie west jamie west
is
rocking shouts out to you you are
walking away with a hoodie jamie
uh a brand statter a brand statter
he shouted me out he shouted you out
kelly and he shouted you out cabbie
for just for the love just for the love
abram you were walking away with the
hoodie
uh finn sanity five
insanity five shouts out to you i've
seen you before he got the jovel
mcgee uh not the joel joellen b gift
going
shouts out to you bro slim reaper slim
reaper 22
you're walking away with it buddy buddy
let's get to let's get to the
the three by two tonight because i i'm
excited
people and you know what we'll give away
some hoodies later on the show what do
you think
yes yeah of course of course of course
you know
so we are rocking with the three by two
once again earlier today we asked on
twitter
put out a poll with will there be two
three-pointers made
in the first three minutes of the dallas
versus philadelphia game
there's the poll and overwhelmingly
america is riding with the yes
79 of the vote listen philly has three
starters
that shoot 40 from downtown
and they have danny green so we're in a
good spot
so g-money how confident is the audience
in the comments
that this one hits
cabbie let me ask them hey audience how
confident
are you that this actually just say yes
i need all type of creative ways
of you guys saying yes different
languages we are writing
emojis different languages why not
emojis
just get creative do do do do your thing
you guys do it all every every week you
guys do it
uh we are riding this cabbie we we've
been riding this
all year but kelly kelly kelly kelly
are you riding with this or you leaning
the other way
greg every single week we go over this
my dude
yes i'm writing this i'm gonna save the
long-winded answer and tell you
fanduel is giving out free money with
this bet it is 9-1 on the season i'll
let you guys do the math i know it can
be hard for some of you but
this is not something you want to
overthink gabby already said the phil
the philly side hello luca it's good for
three in the first couple of minutes of
the game i'm telling you it's gonna
happen
bet the yes i'm right there with you
kels if don if don just continues his
recent hot streak
little three on one side on the other
side if it's cork maz
or tobias harris who's recently you know
snubbed for an all-star reserve spot he
might want to come out firing
and then there's danny green oh for sure
the three by two in this dallas philly
game
that definitely hits um g-money who's
riding with us
cabbie we have a a whole bunch of riding
with us
uh here we got dude with game he says
not happening ooh that is a little bit
of bad luck
guess what guess what though guess what
guess what
guess what guess what we treat that with
kindness we're gonna give you a hoodie
dude uh here we go no no i don't want to
give that guy a hoodie next
all right kelly has spoken no hoodie
h-town h-town everybody's saying no
doubt no doubt the 3x2 was hitting uh
shout out to you h-town
and everybody you're walking away with a
hoodie i got
rainey uh joche 23 says
uh he got the medea gift going you got
the medea gift i'll let you guys see it
it says uh
hell to the yeah all right shouts out to
you and i got one more
gift usage b smith b smith 435 got the
deadpool gift you guys see that right
there
nod in his head yes he is riding with us
shouts out to everybody i said
you're walking away with a hoodie except
the one kelly
took back oh now i'm going to get hate
tweets thanks greg can we
producers can we please give that dude a
hoodie but just remember
who loves you yes hey but again not
great comments make sure your advice
no bad vibes uh listen no bad buys but
make sure
for me happy cabbie i just got to tell
the people i got to tell the people to
make sure to come on
over to the br betting
instagram live we will be riding the
three by two
we need a lot of good vibes a lot of a
lot of good vibes and a lot of sunsets
actually right now i need sunsets in the
comments
sunsets in the comments give me sunset
emoji sunset gifts
fill the comments up with sunsets i'm
giving away hoodies
i gotta interrupt i know that's not part
of the show but since greg just plugged
his after this show show can you plug
our after this show show with fanduel
sure uh tnt vets tonight on the tnt app
join us kelly and i
dallas versus philadelphia from a
betting perspective a lot of fun
and kelly always wins us money so it's
basically
kelly here wins his money and kelly
there wins his money so if you're
interested in winning money
come rock with us um so after before you
tap in with greg on the br instagram
channel on the ig live
make sure to check out the pre-game show
on nba
inside the uh sorry tnt's inside the nba
to see where charles barkley is riding
is he riding with us
in the three by two or if he is he out
on his own
and potentially will take the l uh and
also make sure to tap in with fanduel
to get the three by two prep because
that's the only place in sports betting
you get the three by two so salute to
our friends at fanduel sportsbook listen
there are three
all-stars that are playing in this
dallas and philadelphia game tonight
and since the sixers are at home joel
embiid might give us
all of the celebrations tonight he loves
to do it for the fans even though there
aren't fans
in attendance he still loves to do it
for the fans we might see the iverson
we might see the airplane might see the
rock the baby
but then there's luca doncic and luca
doncic can kill
all those vibes i mean this is what it
did to the celtics like two days ago
doncic the handles the fake
the fade it's pure luca
doncic doncic
down to three seconds two seconds
conscious for the win
oh yeah luca duncan's
the decker
[Applause]
man in the span of like six months luca
has two iconic game winners are from the
same
spot too against uh playoff team salute
to luca so
the question we're asking you tonight is
who will score more in this head-to-head
match-up
luka doncic or joel embiid g-money i
know the comment section is going to be
on fire with
either luca gifts or joelle gifts what
are you seeing so far my dude
i'm seeing a bunch of sunsets cabbie
shout out to everybody that dropped the
sunsets
byu fan 1984 you're walking away with a
hoodie
all right here we go i need everybody to
get in the comments now
comment luca or joel embiid who do you
think is gonna score
more points tonight comment give me
gifts
run them comments up but right now we're
going to talk to kelly
kelly knows value kelly knows numbers
now kelly
we got joel embiid we got luca doncic
who do you think is scoring more points
tonight
no disrespect to luca because i needed
those two monster threes to cash my
dallas money line ticket the other night
over boston
but luca kind of looks like a square dog
tonight joelle
minus 122. luca minus 104. everyone
loves luca i love luca i'm going to give
him some props in the next segment
but this segment's all about joel embiid
he's going to take over tonight i expect
a big game for my dude we all know
philly plays better at home i didn't get
to the window
with philly minus four and a half i
think it's up to five five and a half
now depending on if porzingis plays or
not
but i do lean towards the over in this
game which means both guys are gonna
have a big game but i think joel embiid
scores more
in february both dudes are averaging 32
points a game and luka doncic has to do
more
with less help on the effect of the
offensive side but as kelly said
the sixers are at home they're 13 and
two
and dallas will not be able to handle
all the tools and embiids back dallas is
a bottom 10 defense
and b will have his way with them so i
i'm with you kel's
joel embiid to outscore luca doncic
tonight in their head-to-head match-up
book that g-money who's who in the army
is riding with luca
and who's riding with joelle
tabby i knew i knew i just knew
i just knew the comments was going to do
this it's just it's just a bunch of
lucas it's a bunch of you
got the luca gift right there yeah it's
lucas has taken over
luca gibbs right there uh shouts out to
you
mando uh zero three zero three
uh here we go i'm moving on i see
joellen b
e l c h i l chief stevie l
chief stevie got the joel and b going
shout out to you you're walking away
with the next one cabbie i'm just gonna
call it
i'm just i see luca luca luca all right
here we go uh
neck neck 42 neck 42 he said luca your
shouts out to you you're walking away
with hoodie so guess what
cabbie i am a man of the people i am
riding with luca doncic i mean
he if he is the mavericks team to me
like they go when he goes so in order
for
them to win luca has to have a good game
today and uh hopefully he scores more
than joel embiid well we'll see tonight
at 7 p.m eastern on tnt
um if anybody knows the status of brian
colangelo's burner account
it's probably tweeting about joel embiid
for mvp
but then luca doncic has entered the mvp
chat
as an all-star starter and then game
winners that
light up basketball twitter so let's
take a look at the current mvp odds as
offered by fanduel sportsbook
there's still lebron up top at plus 170
he's been in that position basically all
season
but there's been some movement over the
past couple of weeks joel embiid
right there is number two at plus 350.
nicola yokic still in a mix at plus 550.
but look at some of these long shots
that are tasty luca doncic plus 1100
steph curry plus 1200
dame dalla and kawhi leonard at plus
2100
g-money do you think this does anybody
have an embiid or luca futures ticket in
the comments
hey if you guys got a luca or embiid
futures ticket
let me know in the comments but uh also
talk about who do you think should win
mvp this year or who do you think is
going to win mvp
send gifts write their name type it out
send us whatever in the comments fill it
up but i want to talk to kelly
i got to talk to kelly kelly uh you know
you've been throwing a little darts but
that but there's nothing wrong with that
are you still throwing darts or ah
first of all i don't bet prop bets like
this greg there's no darts being thrown
my job is to discuss the mvp
from the numbers perspective did i say
last week the week before and the week
before that the lebron was probably
going to win it he probably is but
you're late to the party so stop that
nonsense
it's too late to bet lebron you know who
else is too late to bet jokic
and joel embiid you're late you had it
way better numbers don't jump on the
bandwagon now you're wasting your money
i said i was going to give lucas some
props
do i think lucas is going to win mvp no
but i think at plus 1100
to provide some value because he does
have an outside shot to do so
i do again think lebron is going to win
it but if you're trying to bet 170 now
to lock up your money between now and
june
you're too late stop that nonsense look
for somebody
farther down the list this is not a prop
bet that you can
hedge and guarantee yourself money greg
remember we talked about hey if you
think
the utah jazz are going to go deep into
the playoffs you can hedge them in the
western conference finals
or before the finals then great but you
can't hedge mvp
so go with somebody that gives you some
good odds eleven to one fifteen to one
as cabbie mentioned even twenty one to
one
21 to one yet okay so i love what damian
lillard is doing
with the portland trailblazers without
cj mccullum and without yousef nurkich
the guy is averaging 30 points a game
and the blazers are fifth in the western
conference like that's amazing and he's
been lighting up the league from
downtown
but i still like nicola jokic
mvp or nba writers love
narratives they love first-time winners
and this guy just dropped 41 points
on the portland trailblazers and i'm
gonna get a little nerdy right now but
when it comes to per which is a very
important metric
for us for player performance player
efficiency rating
nikola jokic leads the nba and on
basketball reference there is an mvp
tracker nikola jokic again at the top of
the mvp tracker with a 41
probability that he'll win mvp so plus
550
aren't it's not the longest odds but i
think that's the best shot
for uh for this year's mvp so i've
i'm locking in nikola jokic at plus 550
on fanduel
um so here's my question g money
the lakers have lost five of six lost
five or six games
so is lebron still the favorite in the
comments
or is it still the favorite out there in
the uh twitter sphere
uh i'm seeing a lot of joel embiid in
the comments to be honest
i mean i do still see see some lebron
don't get me wrong
but do you know who else i see gabby
who's that see a lot of kevin durant
kevin durant in the comments i mean that
was my pick
that was my pick uh originally but uh
who knows oh i also see damon here let
me give away some hoodies why not here
we go uh finn sanity you already got one
uh max rexel shouts out to you you are
walking away with the hoodie
uh rainey raymie you already got a
hoodie raider909 raider909 shouts out to
you you're walking away with hoodie
uh spicy dubs got joel embiid
you are walking away with a hoodie spicy
uh
gabby the comment is all over the place
i can't even get a grip on it
i i even see yogurt shout out to striped
giraffe 45.
you're walking away with a hoodie uh
what about you where are you
where are you leading in the mvp debate
i'm i'm i'm
i'm i'm i'm i'm thinking about it i'm
thinking about it you mentioned somebody
i really like
so i my heart is with kd but katie's
hurt right now you know
he's hurt so i think that that's gonna
uh take a toll or
or that's gonna be a factor in the
voting at the end of the year so
uh with that being said cabbie i'm i'm
you do you know what time it is
right now do you currently know what
time i do oh yeah
it's dame it's dame time i'm rocking
with dame man he's averaging almost 30.
the blazers are fifth in the west havi
they're just a win streak away
from being two three seed they get to
two three seed matter of fact dame
we need to put respect on his name right
now but if they get up there to the two
to third
seed go on a little winning streak put
some respect on this man's name
there's no way he should be 2100 right
now plus 2100.
okay respected damian lillard and
respect to
the nasa team that landed the
perseverance rover
on mars which seems to be easier
an easier job than greg ivory hitting a
five
leg single game parlay our our homie is
019.
kelly do you know anybody at the jet
propulsion lab that can help greg out
nah but i guarantee there's some guys in
the comments section that are on nine on
their parlay since we started too so
give greg some love i told him how hard
it is to bet a five teamer these are not
things i know our our instagram and our
twitter is full of them
these are not easy feats so greg going
three and two just remember
if he bet those prop bets straight he'd
be making money
thank you kelly thank you i i'm actually
gonna give you another little shout out
here
i even told kathy this on our vet stream
the other night i was like mantras
harold
i didn't see that guy coming out of
anywhere and there you were you had him
over to score 10 points i think that hit
before halftime
yeah yeah yeah and you know you see the
james harden we got we got
caught by the hook right there that's
what filmmakers do
that is okay we got caught by the hook
but that is okay because i'm feeling
real confident about this one cabbie i
don't
okay i don't know about you in the vibe
but i'm feeling confident about this one
are we ready to get into it you need you
need confidence so tonight it's new
orleans and milwaukee
is your single game parlay it's the
second game in the tnt double header
g-money good luck my dude
all right all right here we go let's get
to it man starting it off we go start
off with lonzo
ball we're gonna go over 14 and a half
points for lonzo he's uh been picking it
up he's been shooting that thing
abby lately he's been shooting that
thing actually it's 15 and a half
i'm sorry 15 and a half that's just
another point go get a bucket lonzo
moving on moving on chris middleton
cabbie
he got snubbed he did yeah in the east
that's right
you don't think he's gonna ball today i
think he is
so i think he's gonna go over two and a
half threes
i do think he's gonna knock down three
threes today
i think he's gonna have a game i mean
he's gonna have to make a statement he
got snubbed cabbie
moving right along moving right along my
guy bi
bi brandon ingram go grab some
boards today cabbie go grab some boards
i'm going
over five and a half brandon ingram is
110 pounds my dude what do you mean go
grab
he's long he's he first off he's long
second off you know he can catch a long
rebound he gets
a long rebound i mean really
but i mean we're gonna
i don't know we're gonna see they got
they got hernan gomez
eating up a lot of boards out there
while stephen adams has been like in and
out of the lineup a little bit
so well good luck i mean that that's the
one that's like a little
i don't know about that one bi likes to
score i don't know if we like to do the
dirty work in the paint
hey cabbie maybe a little offensive
rebound you know put back
man we're gonna see we're gonna see here
we go moving right along we got
zion zion zion
we're gonna go six plus
uh over six rebounds so my guy
zion he's gonna go over six rebounds
lock that one in i think zion's gonna
grab boards
uh moving on and we're gonna close it
out with this one
we are gonna close it out with this one
giannis
we got giannis going over 25 points
giannis is gonna ball today
uh lock this one in i'm feeling good i
am feeling good go ahead cubby i see the
look on your face
i'm feeling good about this but zion is
like he's featuring the offense more
stan van gundy's like okay we got to get
this
kid uh you know to run the poor so he's
kind of like a point
forward so he's been distributing a
little bit again i don't know about the
rebounds
homie i think those those two rebound
props one of them might
hit but i don't think both of them are
gonna hit good luck
and i don't mean to bring bad vibes but
i'm concerned about the rebounds from bi
and zion well just to
defend you know my my pick zion you know
when he
often when he jumps he jumps faster than
you know the other person so like i'm
i'm i'm leaning on him
to get some offensive rebounds off of a
missile against lopez
i mean that's a that's a tall order
literally and figuratively it doesn't
matter it's it's yon i mean
zion zion it doesn't matter anyway
anyway can we pull up the uh the ticket
please
we put tickets enough uh enough uh
only 12 to one come on greg enough bad
vibe
uh 12-1 12-1 you guys see it turn your
50 into a quick little
six and some change a little quick six
and some change
but yeah there it is that that is it
lock it in and we
are riding uh the same game
parlay can you can you do you think you
can get a win
on the board before uh double digit
losses again
you are 09 homie
yeah i mean i'm very confident cubby i'm
very very confident like kelly said if
we was the single bet these
huh i would be in the green i guarantee
that but
you know i'm gonna get one of these
parlays i'm gonna get one of these
parlay
okay excellent um listen um
the good news is g-money will continue
giving out hoodies
regardless of how his parlay performs
i mean that's that's that's that can i
give out some right now worse
let's go let's go let's go here we go
aaron's cool greg is smart shout out to
you you're walking away with a hoodie
here we go
uh chyna bynum they're agreeing with me
they like my saint they like my same
game parlay shout out to you i'm feeling
the
vibes i am feeling the vibes uh duo
frigas duo frigas he says bi is gonna
ball out i agree with you bi is gonna
ball out and we need him to grab
rebounds rebounds rebounds shout out to
you you're walking away with a hoodie
uh cabbie should i keep going mikey
locks
i see you mikey mikey okay yo
you guys remember when you see friends
with mikey lock
okey yo shouts out to you you were
walking away with honey jay lewis 67
that's it team greg he's walking away
with their
yeah shout out to the comments man i
love you all thank you for tapping into
the group chat presented by fanduel
remember what you learned today
the mvp debate won't stop until july
it's always game time so put some
respect on his name
and the three by two is easy money so
ride with us america
alongside kelly stewart and greg aubry
my name is cabby richards and we are
leaving the group chat peace
[Music]
you